Admiral Mullen became chairman on
october first of this year and he stands
in the long lineage of names like Omar
Bradley Nathan twining max Taylor Tom
Moore colin powell and many other
honorable men and who observed the
country and I've had the personal
privilege of working for Admiral Mullen
on tasks and I really want to extend a
warm as possible welcome so if we could
give them a round of applause welcome
thank you
thank you very much one might wonder why
I'm here today and I think it's
important to recognize somebody that's
been pretty special in my life and
that's professor bracket before I had
this job and I've only had it a couple
months professor Bracken has
participated on an executive panel for
the head of the Navy for the last
several years and before I was in this
job I was in that job and that's where I
got to know him and he brought great
value to me as a leader of a pretty big
organization sometimes you can get wound
up in the day-to-day details and not sit
back and be able to think too much about
the big picture and I know this is a
course about strategy and among other
things and I'd be interested to hear
your views on what you're learning about
strategy and technology and war I'm
actually very much into all three of
those right now in my current life and
have been for a while but it really is
part of what i consider to be really
it's sort of a to tues thought stream
obligation that that Professor bracket
has given an awful lot of his time to to
the United States Navy in particular
which extends to to the several hundred
thousand three hundred twenty-two
thousand active duty members who serve
in the Navy and their families and I
can't say enough about that and a very
appreciative of all that so when I get
asked to do something like that for
someone who has done so much for us it's
pretty easy to say yes that's one reason
the other is I talked a lot of audiences
most of them actually many of them are
the same age as you but most of them are
military and I think it's important for
all of us in the military and that's all
of us but particularly senior leadership
to get out from those audiences and to
to say a few words to audiences like
this so i really look forward to this as
a great opportunity and what i'd like to
do just over the next few minutes as say
a few things and then really open it up
and he
what might be on your mind I'll tell you
and this is I'm not comfortable doing
this but I'll tell you a little bit
about myself I'm not I grew up in the
50s and 60s I actually grew up on the
west coast I'm an LA guy I don't see any
Lakers hats or Dodgers jerseys here I
see a few others but I grew up out there
and actually grew up in the movie
business didn't have anything to do with
the military at a time actually when
every male role model in my neighborhood
the father's the uncles all had serving
War two but I never gave that much
thought and enjoyed a upbringing in the
same area lived in the same place for
them until I was 17 but I had this
hankering to go east I was a basketball
player I love Bill Bradley as a kid he
was you may not know that but I mean he
was the best there was back then and he
proud and he didn't go to Yale you
probably know that he went to Princeton
one of those other schools but I had
this hankering and I got this
opportunity and I was I was raised as i
said in the movie business but I was
also five kids and and my father
insisted I go to college and if I was
going to go to college and and go
somewhere that that I wanted to go most
likely I'd have to get some kind of
scholarships so the Naval Academy
offered me an opportunity to go play
basketball and come East to Annapolis
never been there never been east been
out of California once actually once to
Iowa once Illinois got on a plane food
of Baltimore the end of June it was 95
degrees it was ninety-five percent you
made I got off the airplane i said i
cannot believe people live in this
because in California if you go to the
dictionaries in California you can't
find the word humidity it's gone so I
hadn't experienced that and and but that
first day met a group of people my
classmates
where your plebs at the Naval Academy
but my classmates who were great people
from all over the country and some in
some cases all over the world and many
of them are still my closest friends
some 40 plus years later very special
people became a very special place as
this is to you and it's something that I
just never looked back from didn't have
any plans actually initially had not
planned to stay in the Navy and and and
the Navy kept giving me responsibility I
got out to see the world first war was
Vietnam that's what I grew up here in
and I went to my first combat deployment
in 69 and and that influences me greatly
and how I think and how I lead right now
and I remember those times growing up
not just in the 60s and 70s but where we
were as a nation where we were as a
military and looking at how that the
relationship of where we were then to
where we are now and it was vastly
different in many ways but also not
there are certain certain certainly some
comparisons that I think are valid given
the conflicts that we're in right now
and and and the world that we're living
in and I'll talk a little bit about that
later on but the point is I had no plans
to do this one of the things I always
try and courage young people do is don't
don't burn all your bridges at one time
you just never know what life is going
to bring you never know what
opportunities are going to be out there
and they are vast and what happened
after i graduated from Annapolis i find
myself on the deck of a ship which I'd
never been on in my life save a save a
midshipman cruise while i was at
Annapolis headed off to Vietnam to see
the world i saw hong kong i saw Japan I
saw the Philippines I went to Hawaii in
addition to getting into the middle of a
pretty tough wore back then so it just
opened opened up my eyes i enjoyed that
a great deal and I have enjoyed the Navy
and serving in the military literally
every day since and what's happened to
me is just additional responsibility
again originally
in the Navy you seek to command ships
and I was given that opportunity never
had any plans to stay beyond 20 years
and then lo and behold additional
responsibilities added on and it was an
area that I enjoyed a great deal
provided for my family raised to two
sons who were thriving and we lived all
over the world lived in the Philippines
lived in Italy lived from Bremerton
Washington down to San Diego California
and on this coast loop from Newport down
to Norfolk Virginia so we we've seen a
lot and it's and all that time back to
what I said before the people that I
have been around have been the best
people i could imagine in the world so
you don't know what life's going to
bring and i certainly didn't and as
Professor Bracken said i had this job
for two months believe me last summer
the last thing in the world i thought
was going to I'd be doing it was being
this assignment I had been in charge of
the Navy for two years it's normally a
four-year tour I expected two more years
and my wife and I were going to I was
going to retire and do some traveling
some of things that we haven't able to
do and this freight train came running
by me and ran right over me and I did
not see it coming that said it's a
tremendous privilege to be able to serve
at this particular point in time and
then that's something else that I think
is really important and I didn't grow up
thinking I needed to serve I wanted to
serve but that's another piece that has
grown on me over time is service in this
case service to our nation in uniform
but we're in it we're at a time and a
nation and I believe in a world where
that service is absolutely vital and it
certainly doesn't have to be in the
military but serving others and what I
found is I've gotten I've gotten back a
whole lot more than I ever gave when I
did that so so it's been a it's been a
tremendous run in that regard certainly
many things unexpected and and very
challenging very stimulating and in my
case I like variety and I get
a variety every day believe me there
isn't one day one professional day in my
life that was similar to the one that
was before or any before it I've met
peoples from all over the world I mean
in recent times just in the last couple
of years traveled to Vietnam back to
that first war nice to go back to a
place in North Vietnam which was where I
first fought on the on the gun line off
the shore there supporting Marines and
soldiers ashore in 1969 nice to go back
and see a country that's thriving that
welcomes you people smile that are look
their economy is thriving and see
parents raising young young children and
pretty positive about their look their
outlook for the future their China
Pakistan India many countries in Europe
South America many countries there as
well so it's provided me a view of the
globe that sometimes is very difficult
to get back here in New Haven or other
parts of the country and and yet this
globe is getting smaller and smaller
we're all more connected we're all more
interdependent certainly and the big
driver for that in the long run is going
to be the the economic piece of this and
as I've I can remember sitting with a
mother in Kosovo in not in 2004 in a
trailer she'd gotten thrown out of her
homeish all she wanted to do was getting
this was the war this is the Serbs and
the Albanians in the in the late 90s you
may remember but five or six years later
she still couldn't get back into her
house and all she wanted was a chance to
get back into her home and raise her son
and take care of her and I find that to
be a universal value in every country
that I'm in as families trying to to
raise their children to a higher
standard of living in a safe and secure
environment so the the opportunities
that the cert life of services provided
him and have far exceeded anything I
ever expected and I would just commend
that again opportunity that's out there
to you
and service in whatever and they're just
been not just myself but too many people
who've come back and said they've gotten
so much more than they ever gave and
that the need is there is unquestioned
in the current in my current job I am as
Paul indicated I'm the principal
military advisor to the president the
united states for the President to the
Secretary defense secretary Bob gates to
the National Security Council which is
the group of principal cabinet members
that have that that debate and decide
issues on national security and also to
the Homeland Security Council which is a
relatively new council that's been set
up since nine eleven as I flew in I was
just out in the middle of Pennsylvania
at one of our colleges at our at
Carlisle our army war college out there
but as I flew in this morning and I and
as a west coast as a West Coast kid I
didn't have much family back east but I
did have an aunt down the road here in
Westport so I'm not unfamiliar I spent a
great deal of time in Connecticut over
the years but I men and in New York and
I love I've come to some of my West
Coast buddies actually accused me of
abandoning my everything that I stood
for on the west coast and now I'm an
East Coast guy but getting just flying
in today and I'm reminded of and being
this close to New York of what happened
some six years ago in New York City
where we lost three thousand-plus people
in that attack and that's something
that's on my mind every single day and
that changed I was actually in the
Pentagon that day the plane and the
Pentagon flew in under my office I was
about 50 yards down their own in another
office but one of my couple of my
assistants looked out the window and saw
a 757 fly in under their feet so what
happened in New York what happened there
what happened in Pennsylvania speaking
of being there today is forever on my
mind and it is
it is branded there and something I'll
never forget and I said that day and
believe today it flipped the world
upside down and and I believe that and
so what I spend a lot of my time on
right now are the major challenges at
the strategic level of dealing with this
conflict that we're in and we're going
to be in it for a long time and it is a
there's there's an awful lot it's back
to sort of this global view there's an
awful lot going on out there that is
tied to radical jihadist extremists the
proliferation and availability of
weapons of mass destruction and actually
it is the convergence of those two
things which is truly alarming as truly
alarming potential for me in addition to
areas of instability and it is easy and
right to focus on the Middle East I'm in
very I'm encouraged and mindful very
much of the meeting that occurred
yesterday in Annapolis the Annapolis
conference because the
israeli-palestinian peace of that
instability is a is clearly one of the
issues at the heart of achieving
stability in that part of the world and
it is a tough problem it's been there a
long time in addition in addition to
being in Vietnam I was I happen to be in
the Mediterranean in the middle of 73
war as well and so I I've seen that and
experience that throughout my life but
I'm encouraged by the steps that were
taken yesterday but it's I'm talking
about the broader Middle East and
stability there Iraq clearly Afghanistan
but on the eastern side of that of the
Middle East Iran and on the western side
the palestinian-israeli peace and there
are a lot of other things in between
that I think that that are tied to our
interests in this country we we call
them vital national interests stability
or instability there
affects us directly and I think that
will be more that will be the case
increasingly over time until we start to
see some stability there but it's not
just there you don't have to spend much
time looking in other parts of the world
to look at Africa in fact I one of the
questions I just got at Carlisle was was
about Darfur and the comparison in
Darfur what's going on there now versus
what happened in Rwanda in the early 90s
and why can't we do anything about that
and the and the international community
is struggling with figuring out how to
reach that and yes this is it and yet
this is a sovereign continent a
sovereign sovereign nations there are
alliances which are addressing that so
it isn't just it isn't just as easy to
say let's all go do this and get it done
and many many issues associated with
that growing certainly the chaos that is
there in northern Africa which is
fertile ground for terrorists and their
growing them there and it's what I there
in call what I call uncovered spaces
where where the government is not strong
there are there are those kinds of
places in many parts of the world even
in our own hemisphere and one of the
things from the United States
perspective that I have grown up and
this is as someone that didn't grow up
very far from Mexico we don't look north
and south very well we have a tendency
to look east and west and I think that
what i see is is strategically more and
more we're going to have we need to look
north and south and looking at the
potential partnerships the emerging
countries the economic engines that are
in that are south of us in our own
hemisphere as well as the challenges
that are there with some of the
leadership as it moves forward very very
vociferously in terms of pushing hard
against the united states and what we
stand for we need to be mindful of that
and i can walk around the world
and talk about challenges that we have
globally and one of the assumptions that
I make is that we that the United States
will continue to be engaged globally and
for the foreseeable future about as far
out as I can see so it isn't just about
this long war it isn't just about the
the weapons of mass destruction
potential it's about the instability
it's also about pandemics it's about
natural disasters we have a significant
size group of people right now in
Bangladesh providing humanitarian
assistance and disaster relief when
they've lost over 3,000 people in the
recent floods certainly you're aware of
what happened the tsunami out in
Indonesia India in 2004 Katrina on our
own Shores these things seem to be
coming in a much more rapid rate or I
was asleep at the switch clearly coming
at a much more rapid rate than they used
to and and response responsible response
to them I think is very important and we
are a very wealthy nation with great
resources and my belief is great hearts
to to assist where we can and that's
real it's it's where we can and where we
are invited as well always mindful that
countries all over the world are
sovereign they're proud and they want
very much to try to take care of
themselves so and we need these and we
need partners we need coalition's we
need relationships across the full
spectrum of sectors in our country and
not just the military not just the
government we find ourselves in the
military involve much more now in
humanitarian assistance and disaster
relief with non-government organizations
and they they are prolific around the
world trying to make a difference as
well so that that is the strategic
environment in which I find myself
assuming this job Chloe great focus on
the war in iraq and the war nap
Anna Stan but not singular focus don't
think we can do that because the world's
too big and there's too much going on
and to the degree we ignore parts of the
world that's that's in my view an
increasing risk against the stability
that our engagement often provides and
the partnerships that get created to
assist in that and becomes actually
become foundational for that kind of
stability what keeps me awake at night
I've talked a little bit about it
already one is the Middle East and where
does that go and clearly the fur
actually the first week and it wasn't my
only it wasn't my first trip the first
week I was in this job i went to iraq
and I went to Afghanistan to see for
myself and that's just a leadership
thing for me I I it's very important for
me to get out and see what's going on on
the ground to talk to those who are in
the field executing these policies to
make and to make my own assessment about
what's going on and to listen to them to
listen to them one of the things I've
tried to keep in mind is just three
simple words listen learn and lead and
and it is in the listening that I'm able
to learn and then make decisions feeding
that in into leadership decisions that
are very important and so going out
there and there's been an awful lot of
discussion and I'd been briefed and
seeing the statistics that security was
better in Iraq and and yet I needed to
see it and talk to those who are doing
it and and just be reminded that those
troops that are out there right now are
out there for 15 months straight they
get 18 days some time in that 15 months
to come home but basically they're out
there for 15 months at a crack and that
goes back to my Vietnam days in Vietnam
we did one year deployments and there's
a finite into how long those are going
to last that is true here now but
because our ground forces our army and
our Marine Corps are pressed right now
they're out there for 15 months and
they're coming back for 12 the Army is
the Marine Corps is doing shorter
deployments but they're going back more
often they're out for seven months and
coming back seven at a time great
there's great
sir on them there's also a great
pressure on their families and and one
of the things that's part of the
sacrifice but you miss a lot of
birthdays and anniversaries and holidays
and those things that are pretty special
to all of us that sometimes we take for
granted and again the number of those
you can miss eventually you know that's
got a finite life on it as well so
certainly what's going on there is very
much on my mind security is better the
economy is starting to work there is
reconciliation going on in the provinces
we need quite frankly the next the big
step that needs to be taken is political
reconciliation at the very senior level
and their governments so that that's a
very high priority for me secondly is to
make sure that it's not just about the
here and now that clearly we've got to
focus on Iraq and Afghanistan and the
Middle East but there's a future part of
what individuals like me get paid to do
is figure out what's what's happening
down the road and to be ready for that
and so it's this balance of making sure
we can succeed where we are right now
and then prepare for the future so in
balancing that risk of what's going on
in the future is another piece and a big
part of that is having a vibrant viable
armed force across the the Army Navy Air
Force and Marines active and reserves so
that we can provide the kind of security
and carry out the kinds of missions that
that we get literally tasked from our
nation typically that comes from the
president but really is from the nation
as a whole and continue to make a
difference and it's and be engaged
around the world and back to this long
war it's that engagement piece it's that
relationship piece it's that cultural
piece it's the language these all those
things that we understand better and
better about what's going on in other
parts of the world but I think we'll be
preventative and deterrent for the
future as opposed to and I'd much rather
deter and prevent then get into a fight
but right now we're in 22 and at the
same time we are we are challenged with
making sure we're out and about in other
parts of the world in a preventative
fashion
so and then back to what I said there's
there's great pressure on our people and
on our families because of the pace of
operations over the last five or six or
seven years so that's a that is a second
priority balancing that obviously with
the mission that we have and then
thirdly is this is this whole issue of
looking looking beyond Iraq and
Afghanistan and getting the Global Risk
balance right for the future future is
pretty hard to predict one of the ant
one antidote that I use is and it goes
back and starts in my Vietnam time when
when secretary designate McNamara was
before the Senate for confirmation
nobody asked him a question about
Vietnam when secretary designate Cheney
was before the Senate before he came in
a secretary defence nobody asked him a
question about Iraq and when secretary
designate Rumsfeld was coming in for
confirmation he didn't get one question
about Afghanistan and it speaks to our
ability to kind of look to the future
and know exactly what's going to happen
I'm very comfortable that being out
there it's going to be continued to be
very very challenging and we're going to
need a robust military force to to
represent us and all the things this
nation asks us to do but exactly where
exactly when and exactly what
capabilities it's going to take it
precisely is going to be difficult and
so I come at this from a balanced
perspective we're going to need we're
going to need a balanced portfolio you
won't find me going into going down to
Atlantic City you're going to vegas and
taking all my money and putting it on
one number it's just not my style so to
try to keep it balanced in that regard
as a real challenge there are there are
lots of challenges associated with those
three priorities but trying to develop a
strategy for the Middle East from the
military perspective get it right for
our people and make sure we can carry
out the mission and that we retain and
we don't start to have a drain
significant drain of our young officers
and our young enlisted because I've been
through that again I've been through
that before
and that's very difficult that takes
decades to recover from and also invest
for the future and how do you know how
to invest actually I'd asked I'd want to
ask you what technology should we be
invented since this is about technology
and strategy what should we be investing
in in the future I'd be interested to
hear your answer but how what kind of
investment should we make because we do
that all the time as well and we need to
get that right and that the leading edge
that we have on technology in many ways
is the gap is closing the refreshment
the refresh rate is much more is much
shorter than it used to be and it can be
incredibly expensive to do this and some
of these like like a business we have
some pretty significant capital assets
that cost hundreds of millions if not
billions of dollars to invest in how do
you want get it right to how do you how
do you build it so that you can keep it
current over its life of 20 30 40 in
some cases 50 years which can be very
daunting as well so I viciously to hear
you know from a technology standpoint as
I've talked a little bit about the
strategy aspect of this and as it
applies to the war that were the wars
that were fighting in I'd be inserted in
your views on